my ankle hurt i don't have a contract
coach coughlin he ended up finding me
and all the i was like
[ __ ] i missed the whole preseason the
game started at seven o'clock
i'm not playing i was at home and my
phone ring they said
plexico we got your contract done i walk
in the locker room
i put up my uniform 10 catches and 133
yards and i hadn't played since super
bowl
[Music]
so who we got in the pool hall today we
got big plaques in the building
flaxschool birds what's good baby
i'm living pretty good man enjoying the
retired life a little bit yeah that's
right
you nice on the sticks what's up that
ain't too bad how much money we got on
the table oh how much money hold
up wait a minute we talking money goes
on today
we'll see how it plays out i'm ready
when you ready all right go ahead break
it real quick then
[Music]
so plex you were known to play through
injuries all right 2007 you're with the
giants
and to win the super bowl that year
right what happens before the season
with your ankle well in the off season i
had some bone spurs removed from my left
ankle going into the training camp
i just jump up for a pass over the
middle subconsciously in my mind i
didn't want to put my left ankle down
because you know it was still a little
tender from the surgery
absolutely and so i just come down and i
just put all my weight
on my right foot and i just hear like a
little pop and i just thought i'd just
you know cry one
yeah i'm on my right and i try to run
and cut it hurts when i'm cutting
so i really don't know what's wrong and
so i ended up missing the whole
training camp the whole preseason we get
into the first game of the season
against dallas
i have a good game eight catches three
touchdowns i'm a cowboys fan you ain't
got to rub it
oh man i'm gonna rub it in all the way
so i think i had eight catches 144
touchdown i think it was something like
football so yeah so take that with you
on two bad ankles on two bad ankles the
following week we're playing against the
green bay packers at home
al harris is guarding me he steps on my
foot
and i just and i heard like a crunch
like a
and that's when i kind of knew that the
injury had went all the way south
i had a tendon that was completely
snapped in half with no stability in my
foot or ankle
and the following monday i went upstairs
to jay reese who was the general manager
at the time
and i'm like i can't perform the way
that i want to i can't push off my ankle
i can't push off my foot we'll get some
more tests
see what's really going on so me and
ronnie barnes who was a hair trainer for
the giants we flew down to charlotte
north carolina to see dr bob anderson
and
specialist and a lot of special players
a lot of well-respected one of the best
in the world right he was like you know
i can do three things
number one i can just put him in the
cast for eight weeks but i'm afraid that
if he's in a cast for eight weeks when
he comes out of the cast
his leg is going to be so weak that he's
not going to be able to perform anyway
number two i can break his heel and
reset it
and when he said break your heel i'm
like well that's definitely not uh
i'm not gonna just like you break my
foot on purpose so they wanted to break
my heel and reset it and reattach the
deltoid ligament that i had torn off the
bone
and it was like number three he can
simply just play it's going to be
based on his pain tolerance how much
pain you know he can take john merrill
who's the owner and ronnie bonds it was
like do you think you can go out
and play on sundays and not practice
so you'd be on the field once a week
yeah just just once a week just
on sunday and we know football is so
predicated on practice yeah
it's one of those things nobody had ever
done it then when they asked me the
question
i was like i don't know i'll give it a
try and in the back of my mind i was
like
i'm putting my career on the line for
the team as the season goes on
i go out and play my teammates have no
idea
why i'm not practicing what they think
was like event privilege that you had
yeah yeah everybody was like oh man you
found a loophole in the city
i couldn't tell anybody yeah and the
owner and the trainer they never spoke
about it in the media
eli and myself we spent a lot of time
together
when i wasn't playing i was playing some
of the best football in my life and i
kind of attributed that to
my ankle was in a lot of pain but my
legs were fresh on sunday how was that
dynamic
a lot of times he would give me signals
and the team had no idea
what was going on it was just me and him
on the same page based off of
what we saw on film and how a guy was
playing what was some of his signals
what do you remember from that
oh man it was like you know behind back
down the leg double seam
it was like slant k you know when i got
into the rear zone he would give me the
head knot i was running the slant and
when he gave me the no
i was running the fade kevin gilbrough
who was officer coordinator
he was like man what the hell was that
well what did you just do after hey man
eli gave me the slant signal so i ran
the slant it's the first dam
we broke a lot of rules nobody could
really figure it out
that thing getting real competitive real
quick how are you playing through this
entry though like how are you finding
the energy and the effort to play
through this you know i really don't
know
i would wake up on monday mornings and
my ankle probably like this big around
and it was just trying to get to the
next sunday get the swelling down
get me off my feet and just get it to
the point to where i could just bear the
pain just to play in at the following
sunday
that's incredible man so the ankle
injury bother you all season still you
have your career year though
right numbers wise what do you end up
doing in the regular season do you
remember i think i had like
70 catches a thousand yards and 12
touchdowns
and when i didn't make the pro while i
was pissed why
talking about cats who practice every
day
and didn't put up the numbers that i put
up it pissed me off so bad and when i
got to the playoffs i took it up another
level talk to me
what happened in the playoffs oh man we
just smoked everybody in front of
straight up i was mad man that [ __ ]
pissed me off man
the week of the super bowl so i come out
of the shower and
slip and i like catch myself maybe i
you know kind of twisted my knee a
little bit and i turn on the light
and i look at my knee and my knee is
like swollen like all the way around
you got the ankle and the mcl
all on one damn leg fast forward to
sunday
they wrap my knee up they give me some
really really really good medicines
i really
man i feel like i had a bought a knee
off ebay or something
i was feeling fantastic fast forward to
the game
to the fourth quarter at this point too
how's your knee feeling how's your
laughing i'm saying to myself i say you
know what man
my knee's killing me i said you know
what it's a super bowl
if i gotta jump off of this leg like
it's not hurting
if i turn my knee up then [ __ ] it
and the ball couldn't come down fast
enough when i was just saying to myself
i said man
if you drop this football you will not
be allowed back in new jersey
still to this day even as time goes on
it starts to mean
even more to you antonio pierce is over
there they ask you now go devils
he said you sacrificed your future
earnings that season
yeah with what you did i did with the
players respecting kind of what you were
doing as they started to find out
what it took for you to be on the field
i think later on
they started to understand the severity
of my injury
but you know i put it all on the line
for myself and then
after that season i did not work out or
run
for like six whole months after the
superbowl i couldn't run
i didn't run nowhere i said man i'm
gonna take this time off to heal up
and to get myself better so i can go out
and play
you know for the season
just hanging my zone man this boy been
practicing
food on this yeah
[Music]